yes sorry everyone this is ian
[Applause]
nia vardalis turned her real-life
wedding into a cultural phenomenon
ah the pensive bride
look at me what lays ahead more like i'm
probably thinking here's the thought
bubble how can i make some money off
this wedding
she produced a one-woman show of the
same name garnering some high-profile
fans this all came about because of an
ad that was like that big in the was it
just by the title my big fat greek
wedding i thought that that i've got to
go see something called my big factory
wedding mia's story had the stars
flashing back to their own wedding maybe
some cultures specialize in throwing
good parties a different sort of like
holidays and family occasions you don't
do bad with a greek wedding man you know
it's it's a pretty fun but i think what
tom's leaving out is that he actually
picked up a table in his mouth and
danced around with it actually it was a
chair i didn't pick up a chair with my
teeth it was a table was it a table yes
it was how much fun we were having
because i can't remember may i
please date your daughter
no
for john corbett 2002 was his year for
on-screen proposals
god but
it's such a beautiful ring
i've asked quite a few women to get
married this year in the movies and tv
finally once said yes hey angelo hey ian
we're gonna kill you
the more bizarre it is in the movie the
more likely it is to be actually pulled
from my true life like the windex i woke
up the wedding of the morning and had
huge zit on my cheek hello ladies fresh
baklava
following a soft debut in the spring my
big fat greek wedding gained enormous
momentum that summer
thanks to some unprecedented word of
mouth buzz and in total it grossed over
350 million dollars at the box office
worldwide we would have been happy at 5
million
so this is already you know beyond our
wildest expectations we're just shocked
and surprised i'm just happy that
everybody's having a good time they're
enjoying it and it's bringing some
laughter into people's lives
what i thought was going to happen is it
would be released in theaters and make
like its budget back and then go to
video and you know be shown in church
basements for the rest of my life
ian is a vegetarian
he doesn't eat meat oh that's okay
that's okay i make lamb i really think
that because greek people surprising to
everybody to hear this actually know
other people than greeks told other
people and i think that really helped
word of mouth
while the movie's tv adaptation was
canceled after one season its popularity
endured and 14 years later the cast
reunited on the big screen these are the
colleges i'm applying to why do you want
to leave me
payback
i think it's kind of extraordinary that
we got the entire cast back together
again and nia wrote a script that was
the right script for the this time in
life so i think that the sequel actually
has a real authenticity to it and it's
damn funny the parthenon wasn't built in
a day you know
it takes time
[Music]